hmm okay hello and welcome to our monday
night show the first first note the last
show before my small smallish vacation
break next week so I won't be on next
week but looking forward to the show
tonight hello to all of you in the chat
I'm going to see if I can get some cool
oh five minute games game ok here we go
f MGM gatos something and tough handle
ok so the Scotch feeling sharp tonight
meat grinder asks perfectly honest nope
the thing is it's been a super long day
I hope I'm I'm playing okay it's a it's
been a very long day of teaching got
lots of things to do
there's a question by vladimir me Soren
my English super serious on the English
opening for chest when you fry okay well
this is a stream for the icc so i want
to elaborate much but i have something
in the works down and then I g2 line um
then that g2 and against the Benoni it
looks too rosy from the shunt off-book
you think I don't know it just looks I
don't think it this is particularly good
and this line I think it's not
particularly good for black modern been
only has a couple of problems and this
is one of them okie dokie what's going
on here d5 looks normal so what's the
deal here i can go d6 like normal stuff
was something more what do you five I
think t5 and random jelly ask what what
am I thinking about yeah Gustafson's
bashing of the zurich variation in one
of his opening clinics I don't think
bashing is correct I don't I don't
really know I mean he featured the
zurich variation in one of his video
series and he came to the conclusion
that white is slightly better which is
too I'm I never claimed that black
should be fantastic actually I give I
give this line in my book and white is a
little bit better but it's not it's not
the end of the world from for black
either okay this is more of a problem
here this is a somewhat awkward pin
I try to get the bishop pair here but my
king position is shaky of course okay so
after the capture he wants to he wants
to take with the f porn it seems
interesting okay can go Queen f6 maybe
and play Knight f form let's see I don't
see a big drawback for white in the
nigeria line against the Benoni it's
very often given as good for white also
by other theoreticians to be perfectly
honest I mean shunned off has made
history here this is a good book but
very often I am I other I often have
other opinion let's say then he has he
has some things in his books that I
simply don't understand but that bin
only line is fine why doesn't need a
white doesn't need a particularly direct
plan against the Benoni if you can make
your Center solid you are a lot better
anyway because you have more space the
typical be known anything in the
bandoneon white is simply a lot better
unless black can drum up something
special and if you can keep the center
solid you should be yeah should be in
excellent shape yeah this is not looking
good here absolutely not my king is bad
and I've got lots of weaknesses so guts
GM guitars ya got a great position here
you don't need a plan you just keep your
you just keep your space that's enough
check
now you can play for before for example
if you like but it's not the only plan
maybe he's going for Bishop f5 yet would
make some sense or this one it's kind of
comparable this idea f5 is very loose
but okay no the Benoni is not that
unsound I don't believe this but the min
the Benoni when wide still has options
regarding the night on g1 I don't know
why I think this is a bit questionable
there is a reason why nobody plays that
if they played the Benoni until they
usually do and after there is a
commitment of the night ok so what about
this
I don't have time which is the problem
okay I'm going back here for okay fate
maybe the snake benoni is also very
borderline and time morning I mean you
can quite always down for almost any
line you will find some game where some
good player has played an opening
because in single games almost anything
is playable but as a regular part of the
repertoire it's very difficult to play
stuff like the snake benoni so how do I
get down maybe just six week ish and
doesn't threaten that much okay maybe
here queen bee to some some time could
be could be good
would be to Bishop b5 I think I should
be winning now at least by position
doesn't have a defense yeah I think pin
him here and check check check white
resins tough very tough random Johnny
says Magnus Carlsen's going to bring the
Stonewall to live yeah the stone wall is
also a lot better than the snake and
only game started okay interracial
master meth man I don't know who that is
who is that chick no name okay okay got
the Kings Indian Marco gone off again
with age three maybe this one I I very
here with them my lines c6 and working
maybe I can do this yeah England is
playing right I couldn't see anything
today he said sooo exciting this
resistance group I think it is right
it's not not yet a clear clear picture
in this group night to see seven this is
I had them something similar in a blitz
game recently and and I couldn't really
figure out why the night goes to c7 him
yeah this is this looks like a king's
indian without i would any any counter
play for black what what are you doing
here math man Sebastian as fussy and ask
about Germany Poland if I bite my nails
no actually not I'm usually I mean those
um in those group games earlier I'm
pretty relaxed I mean it was even with
the loss you still have changed have
opportunities to reduce to do things and
it's not a not a big deal okay so let's
do this
yeah f5
I can even play a 3 there b5 b6 is going
to bulldoze him on the queenside yeah
you know that the germany poland match
what would really really got got quite
obvious i felt i mean i'm not in
football expert but what really got
obvious is that Poland has a pretty
strong team I mean they are just not
easy at all to play and I think whoever
God gets them in the in them in the
knockout round and we'll we'll have to
really really really really work hard to
not get get the ad s kem and the polish
team is good it's just just what it is I
mean okay levendusky is probably the
only world-class kind of player but then
they have a good team they have a couple
of good good guys from Dortmund for
example and also other other players
that are at good club so definitely if
black plays are for now I'm going to
sacrifice on b6 okay
damn this this this line is super
dangerous for black if he doesn't know
his stuff inside out it looks like this
often just like a complete kill yeah I
can take this which do I want to take it
probably and probably not or the other
one yeah this is good
I didn't take the rook ever because of
Bishop f6 stuff it's just easier to play
when you still have the dark squared
bishop the only only after way to avoid
some checkmating stuff some swindle
other than that the position winds
itself Jack ok so what to do this what
to do this what kind of English is that
what to do here let's try with some half
a decent language and okay in Queens
here
congrats to jon Septon who says he won
he won he won his first chess tournament
great it's always winning a tournament
is really something great I mean it's
something that you should be absolutely
proud of okay my ideas queen bee a check
takes root p7
you had the great thing winning a
tournament is really a great stuff
because we read some because it is it is
very difficult yeah I mean you can
definitely you have good results let's
say yeah this is all cool but actually
being first is something that's really
great yeah to know that you have
basically beaten the whole event does
this great stuff so he wants to go Queen
g5 quite clearly I mean and he will
manage there isn't hmm is this some kind
of play I can do this
I just wonder if I have some way of
making it easier
hmm I just saw that he has a bit more
chicks than I thought he has check check
check check check check black before if
it's on how I'm Chris tricky always
tricky whoo yeah let's do another game
what is ebonics ebonics counts as
English what is he bollocks never had
that one Ebonics you can cease to learn
new things oh we've got yard bird yeah
the yard bird he is a really bad waiting
at the moment for his standards having a
bad time it seems I also scored rather
well recently against him oh I can 35 mm
okay it's not the end of the world I'm
not going to play the selectors love it
wait this request that every time I
really don't understand it's not a
particularly interesting opening yeah
you don't get yard good that off man on
the streams it's rather late for him
usually plays during the day and he
really has a bad rating quest and that
is usually the I mean he's usually
around
2400 to 2500 and deservedly so I mean is
a really really good really good blitz
player yeah if I take with the sea pawn
I might get c5 but he gets d for this is
also not very nice I understand that my
bishop is crap on I ate but and okay
well pretty awful the only thing this is
somewhat somewhat resilient yeah PPG
would cost kiss has two day cards and
play an interesting idea in the opening
and the commentators credited Eric
LeBron that's possible Lauren always was
an interesting player in the opening
especially when it came to finding
resources to to fight yeah LeBron always
try to get fighting games going and I
don't know what what you're what you
refer to in particular I didn't see
today's broadcast but it's it's very
much possible that ebonics is okay it's
a stereotype how black people speak
English okay yeah i can it's probably
this kind of it hip-hop hip-hop sounds
sounding english or something
so something like that okay I'm here
yeah
you
that's really not good he's got f4 I saw
that but my position is bad I'm i need
to change the cause of the game and I'm
trying to do this by sacrificing here
the bad thing is i wanted to play 94 of
course but then able sacrifice the
exchange immediately I'm Queen a8 for
example is strong now
maybe I should have played 94 anyway
Queen eight now killed I cannot move
after this
we need a say we need a stream with me
talking hip-hop lingo young man probably
not going to get this right
I actually got a request today by a
message on the ICC that I should play
the Halloween gambit which I definitely
want to this is even worse than then the
channel F Ian
yeah why it is just an exchange up but
it's still kind of tricky
if i take g3 King takes Bishop g4 and
the thing is I'm this is f 5 business
okay I'm bad anyway Queenie one was what
concerned me Kincaid's Bishop takes
Queen e1 concern me but I have Bishop d7
which well it probably wins a hag wins
as well it's what can you do yeah I
thought bishop is six might be something
with this is not doing that much I can
move the rock somewhere
maybe g5 is a move probably not
time-worn angels do this took me ages
okay
so here yeah this is still somewhat
interesting a check here's got king of
tool hmm unfortunate check rookie three
is good don't even have a square
check check hmm please I've got some
chicks here check check check ah roop
the tools that god damn it ok didn't
generate check ok black resigns hmm yeah
hmm I don't know position was somehow
too bad i think very difficult to get
something going there wasn't wasn't very
nice ok who do we get our whole gays
online i probably would have black
against me if it be three again or
something ok what's the standing
standings with the games currently going
on at the matches I'm sorry at the euros
we have Wales and England right but I
don't know where I'm gain starting again
are you serious ok
I mean it's always interesting to play
in but we are in Game 73 now which is
kind of a lot yeah keep it sing I don't
know but there there wasn't anything
great going on yeah this line I don't
like our weights lead Lisa 20 hmm
Russia might be out that's possible
maybe considering how the some Russian
supporters behaved this is not a bad bad
thing
yeah so here we have some some weird
dutch defense the Queen on d3 is funky
if I have a would need a bishop them
that would be cool some of them
harmonized my pieces are this one okay
um yeah maybe just go back here
going for Bishop d3 Bishop e3 next I
would really like to do this yeah so
here interesting I can take then go
95-93 is a move I think I go here it's
it's tough to say yeah I need I need
some non-alcoholic beer think it's a
good idea i have one i have one in the
fridge but specifically for the stream i
try to cut down on it successfully am
too young but should before you might
have 90 x f2 here well if I just give
this I mean I Scott rook f.3d bloody
hell and I don't know it's not so that's
not so great cake steaks look at three
politics but should you find it for her
it's possible yeah i saw that Eric just
too late
so it's it's still not a clear position
at all garage is not German beer that's
a that's a Dutch from the Netherlands
yak this company is totally unclear
position I mean troll Damon probably is
maybe he's better I don't know I don't
really know currently he doesn't have
his half his pieces play Brooke on a
head and so on
OU kounye pill denies mentioned this is
from right right around the corner let's
say it's a it's brewed and induce book
which was my residence for a long time
only recently moved away so this one if
I take their and f3 this kind of okay
when it's not it's not enough what about
what about Queen a force a move that I'm
intrigued by he cannot take them
threatening to take their
25 25 is definitely possible hmm doesn't
do it takes them yeah a strong move
buddy and I can go to g5 actually this
is a funky move I just play that because
it looks cool you can take with the
bishop of course it's no mate I need a
beer ah I really need a beer badly shoot
i wanted to play f3 ok it doesn't matter
really check check ok there was a bang
besides that was a bad one ok I'm back
in a second I need something
ah that would definitely help oh wow
because he has such a CREP rating I'm
below 2400 okay and this was I know it
looked very shaky this is this stuff
here now it defends though it all the
fence hmm ah so I had a good rating and
then yard to add struck twice shoot game
started ok super rotten yeah I'm having
I know it's not alcoholic but still it
Oh get the Scandinavian young chef of
all openings
Wow e 6 wow I thought you would try to
get the bishop more active the c8
version I thought
so one thing I know I'm definitely will
try to check mate him here
always has this f5 resource I can 1 i'm
just going to take first anything later
that might not work at all but um tween
of three hmm I don't know what was so
dangerous about cleaner three okay so I
this was a bluff and build but f 5 mm
it's not really calling my bluff but
it's might not so bad
hmm f5 is still a pretty good defense
surprisingly
hmm my queen cannot really participate
them okay I'm just play the most idiotic
looking move and I mean I'm lost anyway
probably so I just play the self work
just looks totally ridiculous with three
priests has been exposed but it
certainly has the greatest shock value
it doesn't make any sense I'm totally
aware of that it looks so wacky that he
had to pause and okay this is actually
one of the rare moments where it might
make some sense when i played this is a
mess
okay then yeah okay what's one wouldn't
say oh yes one move on ok I can take f5
now but i think this one with potential
night f5s rookie 69 takes here Bishop f6
is probably coming
because you have six I think is good
you
I don't I don't even see a move to be
honest after that
even now I cannot take a five that's not
going to work unfortunately now you have
quite some checks but quite some checks
is not not enough Queen d2 Bishop g5
this is extra this is doing where am I
going now I don't have a good square so
thing
maybe it's got night at four now now
matter for problem
Bishop g5 maybe I can take each size
maybe still somewhat funky not
objectively but it is somewhat scary
well I'm still in the game here time
morning check oh wow I didn't see that
he could take it I got to got them and I
didn't see that at all Jack and night if
he didn't do night
I have four pawns for two pieces funny
enough check check check yeah I mean I'm
not resigning this it's not not that
easy black forfeits on time yeah that is
wow I don't know it was a completely
crazy game but it was fun so let's go
for one more as long as I still have
some of this support in india form
yeah I looked a little bit hug three
minute madness em ya bish of age six
probably bad and I think he can take it
actually but a five was good starting
Ronnie Mia and yeah he plays this
opening and I had this earlier today
against him in a video that will be
released soon Asian yeah this soon this
is not particularly good but it's not
something that you have to remember
correctly yeah I see the point f7 is
always attacked
that wasn't my original plan as you can
probably guess
yeah I just try to attack look see aiden
before yeah Sophia rules in football and
soccer I don't know yeah new lil is kind
of kind of lame I have to agree so I'm
just going to push my pants here don't
want to reinvent the wheel simple simple
checkmate is good okay again it's
probably it's probably all good but this
is probably best I don't know getting
close to that
the question by meat grinder how did I
come to learn that it not expected on
icc was jerry from chess network this is
something that i knew for years I don't
know somewhat somewhat told me and it
was once or twice on reddit and and so
on it's it's nothing nothing
particularly new ok I'm taking this
I guess just this one I'm just trying to
take 35
Wow there are all kinds of things going
on here
so what's this I can move the Queen I
can take his Queen and trade but I can
also move my career if i move from a
queen to h 2 i'm taking his bishop and
i'm taking his queen isn't that good and
it should be
I have non-alcoholic beer here this is
the only be I drink basically I mean
clearly during chasa I never would do
something with alcohol jo I don't think
I'm just winning this is special
93 right see for this kind of thing can
still be quite a quite an attack maybe
orders so okay you're taking here how do
i get close there to to his son to his
position night if five I don't know he
will take here
maybe this 495 I Scott 93 anyway yeah
lets you for this what what the heck
you
and shouldn't there be some kind of made
downtime morning see a maid
unfortunately
Queen B seven but it's not really
threatening anything
check check well I don't have that much
time check check white resigns who tough
he's still managed to swing go awesome
some weird things that we're quite a
fear attaining okay so let's do one more
game and then call it call it a day I'm
actually still quite happy with my
performance I didn't didn't do so badly
and it was a as I said really long day
this line by the way can be very much
recommended against up there is soft
with Bishop g5 it's something that I
think gives black very decent plane you
just basically say okay I'm going to
play like a chicken with Carlos reverse
simply ignoring that black is a tempo
down it doesn't it doesn't really heard
much gain started okay playing Carosi
arrow here in the final game for the
session and try to play relatively
normal stuff I'm still as I'm rather
tired and other ones something that I
know it's not so much the time for some
crazy stuff
yeah g4 I know okay I could have played
Bishop e3 them but ok g4 it's not a bad
line and just not such a huge fan hmm ok
not sure about this move b5 is so
strange ok so he's f6 is hanging let's
start with this with this simple fact if
I move my knight back why isn't that
just a double tap on a 6 + f6
yeah that's just a double attack he will
try to swindle now give up a nice one
resins no we just resigned say which is
which is true i mean it is winning but i
still thought there might be something
coming yeah anyway a six is hanging and
this is hanging I actually cannot paint
a 6 + f6 both hanging at you cannot
cover them both yeah okay that was this
live stream for june twenty i hope you
enjoyed the show this would be M the
show before my vacation break i'll be
off for 10 days i think starting
thursday so i won't be on next monday
but i'll be back on monday the fourth
yeah fourth of july so if you are in the
u.s. you will have a day off and can
watch the stream i hope you liked it
i'll be back in two weeks bye bye
you